hey everyone is sayers registered nurse
ari and.com and in this video I want to
show you how to split a pill so why do
we split pills as nurses well sometimes
a physician may order two milligrams of
a medication however you are only
supplied with four milligrams so that
requires that you split the medication
in half so in this video I'm going to
demonstrate for you how to do that okay
first what you want to do is you want to
perform hand hygiene then you want to
put on gloves and after you put on
gloves you want to confirm that you have
the right medication for the right
patient's right route all those little
checklists that you need to do then you
want to get a pill splitter and this
will help you achieve an accurate test
because you want it to be even and if
you don't get it even it will be in an
accurate dose and these pill splitters
have really sharp blades so never put
your finger there because you will get
cut and they have an area where you put
the pill and it holds it steady for you
as you cut it and you just do that and
it'll snap it in half so we get our
medication and you never want to split a
pill with your fingernails your hands or
some other object always use this and a
lot of these medications come and with a
scored line which help you achieve and
even cut and if you're never sure of a
medication can be cut in half always
call pharmacy and asks in so we're going
to take our peel and we're going to put
it in our peel cutter now you're just
going to close the lid of the cutter and
push down and past it okay so say that
you did this and the peel just
disintegrates into all these little
pieces and you don't know which parts
which and always check with your
Hospital protocol for whenever that
happens places I've worked and they
require that we send it back to pharmacy
so they can credit the patient and that
you start all over and also if this was
a narcotic you would want to waste the
medication
another nurse and don't just throw it
away so always follow your Hospital
protocols with that as well okay so that
wraps up this video on how to split
appeal thank you so much for watching
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for more videos